hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events from the love
people use things tour if you'd like to
see us on the road visit
theminimalists.com
tour or you can find all of our live
events over at patreon.com slash the
minimalists enjoy
[Music]
so my question for
for y'all is i'm actually moving out of
my parents house in like a month
i'm extremely terrified
and also excited so i was wondering if
you can give me any tips
or tricks i'm moving in with my sister
actually here in san antonio i don't
live here i live near here but not in
san antonio
so
let's talk about fear and excitement
isn't it funny that they're essentially
the same thing
and it's basically the story we tell
ourselves which determines whether i'm
excited or i'm afraid
in fact if i
were to go to you and say hey describe
to me like a time when you're really
really excited i might hear something
like my palms get a little sweaty my
heart starts to be a little bit faster
right i start to get kind of tense
and amped up
and i actually describe fear and you
start describing the same physiological
symptoms of fear right
and so it has to do quite often with
the stories we tell ourselves kapil
gupta says that fear is present whenever
there are consequences
and i would say the same thing about the
excitement that you're feeling as well
is the excitement is like wow what is
the consequence of this what is the best
thing that can happen unfortunately what
we often get caught up in is the sort of
catastrophic thinking
what's the worst thing that could happen
right and that becomes i mean it's okay
to understand what the boundaries are
you don't want to jump out of an
airplane without a parachute
understanding what the worst thing can
happen is really useful there
it it helps you
make an informed decision
but quite often we're treating everyday
decisions like moving out of into a home
as though it's jumping out of an
airplane right
and so
um my guess is the thing that you fear
is what
is it is it accumulating stuff
is it
just the new the unknown of the new
space yeah the unknown the new space or
the responsibility of bills or not be
able to handle it yeah the money
problems yeah the drive to work or just
everything the unknown yeah yeah well
get a place closer to work that's the
first thing i would do
uh eight and so you these fears are i
understand it's not even a fear it's
like a discomfort thing right it's a
it's an inconvenience when i was reading
that story earlier from uh the book
about jason and jennifer
what what i found about the
conversations
they
experienced they didn't experience this
incredible terror or fear
it was like a
extreme inconvenience
that all of their things had burned to
the ground
and what a beautiful place that is to be
where
if you lose something it's merely an
inconvenience
right and so with respect to the things
you're fearing here i mean it sounds
like the money side of things yeah of
course money is you know ryan and i are
not allergic to money as minimalists we
have to
we have to earn a living right um we
have quite a large team as well so we
have a lot of people to pay and so we
have our own homes and
um it's important to not go into debt
for me that's something that's a value
of mine i avoid debt i don't think
there's any such thing as good debt
now everyone hears that and they hear me
like say
that i think you're bad if you do have
debt that's not what i'm saying at all i
just want to be clear about that i just
think that keeps us from being free
and so if you value your freedom
you'll want to do whatever you can to
stay out of debt
and so what else are you fearing
[Music]
i have tried moving out before for
college
did not work out
i it was mentally too much for me i got
you and i'm scared of that again
yeah and was there anything about it
that didn't work out in particular like
there were one or two things that you're
like ah this is why it didn't work out
your words by the way uh it didn't work
out because a lot of things were
happening around that time such as
family
passing away and
moving forward living four hours away or
being on medication
that
was not good for me mentally yeah or i
didn't take consistently like i should
have yeah so
i'm scared of that repetition happening
again while i'm living alone
i understand
yeah i'm sorry that it's uh i know that
it's overwhelming and so when something
is extremely overwhelming to me i try to
break it down into chunks right it's
like you try to memorize someone's phone
number remember we used to memorize
phone numbers by the way
there's a reason that it's broken down
the way that it is right is because you
couldn't memorize if i just threw 10
numbers at you good luck with that
but if i give you here's three numbers
okay i can read the area code i got that
yeah all right
all right now the prefix okay figure
that out and then it's just i just got
to remember these last four numbers i
might even chunk that into two numbers
at a time
and why do i do that and so i don't get
overwhelmed by it and just throw my
hands up
and and so
i think the same thing is true whenever
we're making a big life decision you're
you're making what is perc you're
perceiving to be this giant leap right
it's probably not a giant leap it's
probably a bunch of baby steps to get
you there now eventually you'll be there
but it's not just oh my god i have to go
in head first and
no plan whatsoever
i think you covered it all man
i'm just kidding
um
first i want to say uh thanks so much
for the compliment that you started off
with because um
if it was just you who showed up tonight
i would be eternally grateful for that
and every time i hear a compliment like
what you just said it really that is why
josh and i do what we do so thanks so
much for sharing that
um
yeah i mean josh talked about certain
mistakes or certain things to avoid debt
being one of them but the good news is
is that there are also some of these
other mistakes that you don't have to
openly admit right now in front of
everyone that you made when you moved
out the first time
so learn from those mistakes and uh
don't you know just don't repeat the
same things my sister i remember when
she was first moving out of the house
she called me up and she was really
scared about
paying her bills and
um
being able to survive on her own and so
forth and so on and i gave her the same
exact advice i was like just stay out of
debt
get a roommate keep your expenses low
and
i'll tell you it wasn't
as
it wasn't as hard as she thought it was
going to be but it certainly wasn't easy
and that's the advice i'll give you is
yeah it's not going to be easy but i
promise you it will not be as hard
as what you're making it out out to be
are you are you moving four hours away
again or no no you've already minutes
away that's awesome that's incredible
it's from my parents yeah awesome that's
awesome cool
well yeah i wish you the best of luck
and um i i know you're going to do great
especially because uh again you've
already gained a little experience and
you're going to use that to really
succeed this time i hope so for sure i
will yeah yeah you will thanks for your
question appreciate you being here
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free